mr president dear joe
mrs vice president
thank you for calling the second global
covet 19 summit
today's presence of leaders from across
the world is a powerful signal
no issue is more important than people's
well-being
we cannot be complacent
because the pandemic is not over
of course
safe and effective vaccines and better
treatments have much reduced the
pressure on our healthcare systems
and restrictions in many parts of the
world are being lifted
but new variants will continue to emerge
and there is no guarantee that the next
one
will be mild
in addition we must prepare for future
pandemics or other health threats beyond
covet
so in the european union we are working
hard to step up surveillance strengthen
our healthcare systems
and improve preparedness
none of us can do this alone
and this is why international
cooperation and solidarity have been at
the heart of our
eu's response from the very beginning
until now europe exported 2.2 billion
doses of vaccine
in addition team europe helped to set up
and fund the act accelerator and shared
470 million vaccine so doses so far
because we know
global cooperation
including our eu eu-us partnership
is vital to end this pandemic
we teamed up in our fight against covet
at the first summit in september
the joint statement we are making today
proves
that our close cooperation is advancing
the global effort to end the pandemic
at our last meeting in september
we focused on sharing supply and local
production as well as on ensuring
sustainable financing
now we must must take our commitment to
the next level
the supply of vaccines has to go hand in
hand with speedy delivery especially in
africa
today i can announce that the european
commission makes a financial commitment
to enable vaccine delivery in the
countries in need
i also make a financing pledge to
support the work of act accelerator on
diagnostics therapeutics and health
systems
in addition we make sure that all
regions have the capacity to produce
their own medicines
locally the recent agreement in the g20
to move ahead with a global pandemic
preparedness fund
is an opportunity for the global
community
we will work together with the us and
other partners to make it fit for
purpose
i can announce today that the commission
envisages a significant contribution
to this fund as soon as its governance
is established
ladies and gentlemen the development of
safe and effective vaccines in record
time
was an unprecedented achievement in the
history of science
and it was international cooperation
that made this success possible
i'm sure mr president dear joe
that our summit today will strengthen
the global cooperation we need